all right spice
yes spicy where are you from originally
i was born in pomona california pomona
and tell me about your family he had mom
and dad
yes mom and dad
had kids real young in high school they
were never married or together
so i grew up with both of them
separately
and
how old were your parents when they had
you 18.
and then had an older sister that they
had when they were 15.
so we had they were young parents so it
was a wild childhood
in what ways um i mean my parents they
were like partiers not like
nothing crazy but you know we moved a
lot so it always kept it interesting i
think i went to like
nine or ten different like schools i
always switch schools because my dad was
moving and my mom was moving so i was
switching schools when i was with both
of them right yeah you finished high
school i did surprisingly um because i
didn't do nothing in high school i
didn't do anything how are you in high
school i was a bad child for sure i was
always
doing drugs getting into fights getting
kicked out of school not going to school
yeah just getting in a lot of trouble i
rebelled why do you think you were a
bill
um
the first time i pretty much started
like getting high i just didn't want to
stop getting high and it just kind of
spiraled
your parents were into drugs no
my mom never into drugs my dad never in
front of me or to my face i would say
but i think as an adult i kind of maybe
put some things together but no i didn't
really grow up in a
household where drugs were used or
alcohol was abused really um
but i think they say it skips a
generation so like my mom came from
something like that but my mom wasn't
like that interesting yeah yeah that's
how i can that's how we talk about it
but i definitely once i started getting
high didn't stop
how did you get introduced to sex work
um as a bartender so i was a bartender
and i got my first sugar daddy when i
was bartending at hooters and i didn't
know what sex work was
i didn't even know i had a sugar daddy
at the time how did he approach you uh
he was one of my regulars and he would
just tip me really really well and
you know come to see me from month to
month because he was from out of state
and
eventually i kind of put together what
was happening and he was going through a
divorce and i was kind of there for him
but as a bartender like i'm there for
everybody at the bar you know everyone
tells me their problems we all come to
let go of our worries but
with him it kind of just grew into
something
like a sugaring relationship unknowingly
to me but then once i was like oh i can
get this from this guy i kind of learned
how to play it
i learned how to play it
but yeah he
bought me my first car and paid my rent
and all these things before i even knew
how to be a sex worker and then i got
into
bartending at strip clubs and then
started stripping
and how old are you now i'm 29 and i
started when i was 24. so you've worked
at strip clubs and you've also escorted
and and they kind of cross those overlap
quite a bit don't they yeah you know
because no matter what club i'm at like
it's always the potential to meet a
client that wants something more than
dance
a lot of the strippers i'll interview
won't admit that that goes on but that
yeah that is what goes on yeah i think
anyone who says that it doesn't happen
in every club is just you know a liar
but i don't feel like there's there
shouldn't be a stigma around that you
know we have these environments for
certain reasons
it's a safe place right
are drugs still a part of your life no
actually i smoke weed and i drink but
i've been clean
since i was like 21 22. good for you
tell me about how you did that
um
the first time i did meth i was
15
and i never stopped until i got clean um
it was the most like powerful high i had
ever felt i think i had done ecstasy and
cocaine at that point already and i had
drank a lot but once i did meth i just
like
felt
like that movie limitless it really just
took over me and then once you do it for
a certain period of time you just become
a different person entirely and i
evolved into a completely different
person
so from 15 to 20
i
was literally
throwing my life away you know sleeping
with older people for you know drugs or
just dating dealers
um
you know i ran away from home i didn't
go to school for semesters at a time
and
you know i overdosed
once twice once once and then
i was sent to live with my dad in east
l.a to try to like get me clean and i
didn't go to school they wouldn't let me
go to school for like
i think a whole semester because if i
went to school i would just leave and go
get high and they would never be able to
find me again and every time i went
somewhere
people would be shocked that i was still
living they would be like oh we thought
you were dead in a gutter somewhere and
that was a common thing and you got
clean how um honestly a relationship
kind of saved me um
i met him at 16 and we were together
till i was 21 and he knew that i had a
problem and i would lie and hide about
it and like i would pretend to be asleep
in bed when i was sleeping next to him
even though i was high as a kite
and eventually
um
working and because i would do it
sometimes when i was a server or
things like that but once i got addicted
to making money and being in like a
normal relationship i kind of stopped
hanging out with the wrong people and
that was pretty much it it was
just having the love of him even though
that was still toxic it wasn't a great
relationship convincing him you know not
to hang out with these people so much
and i was working at the time so i
really just kind of had no time to get
high anymore and then once i started
working i became addicted to making
money because i couldn't go to work high
i would be way too paranoid i'd be
talking to a customer and be like oh my
eyes shaking or like am i sweating or
like am i talking okay
and so i kind of just weaned myself off
of it fortunately
but
i did relapse once when i first moved to
la uh
five years four or five years ago and i
picked up
and i packed a bowl and i hit it once
and i got so sick i flushed it and i
never did it again
but i did have that moment in my life
and fortunately i got sick and
let it go again
but it was a hard time because i don't
know i should have been dead like i'm
tiny already and i was like 70 pounds
like shoulders sticking out and
still
stealing fighting not going to school it
was just tragic to see a child do that
to itself
but um fortunately
working kind of getting a normal job
because i had a job at 15 and a half so
been working and money always was the
bigger motivation so at least i had that
that's great
and your kids no
i don't want them i don't think so but
yeah no kids no marriages and single
good for you
that's great
what is your goal here you're hoping to
save money maybe
you know
plan for something i have plenty of
different goals i like to have a lot of
little eggs in different baskets so to
speak but
um
i definitely want to be a business owner
and i have some things in the work with
that and i want to get into real estate
um are you saving money yes
very good at that that's great very good
at saving it and very good at spending
it
but in general you're saving money yes
that's rare that's great yeah you know
i'm fortunate that i'm able to pull in
enough money to do that
because it's hard
how does this
this life as a sex worker
affect you emotionally
um i definitely am affected emotionally
i meditate i journal
i pray even though i'm not religious i
kind of just like pray in a form of
giving gratitude and you know i am
blessed to have my health and my safety
still through all that i've risked and
gone through so i definitely
i'm affected by getting away unscathed
like i'm happy but also like i have to
practice
safe things and
uh keep my mental state
positive because it can get overwhelming
it's a troublesome lifestyle yes for a
lot of girls though
you have to be very strong-willed and
strong-minded you can't and like thick
skin
would you
recommend this to any girl who's just so
hard on money
i ever like i have a podcast that i
started doing and i always end it or
start it by saying don't say i told you
to go out here and start doing this i'm
just telling you what it's like because
i wouldn't
i wouldn't wish it on anyone i don't
think because you never know where it
can go that's all i'm saying it can lead
down many different paths
and i don't think a lot of girls know
how to navigate the roads yeah there's a
lot of things you need to learn
but i like put myself through hell in my
early 20s and i grew up really fast so i
feel like
i fortunately
i'm street smart and know how to
navigate my way and i also had you know
work before this that was you know like
hospitality related work so that really
benefited me and i think being able to
talk to customers and you know being a
host environment and having that
professional experience kind of really
helped me but what is being in this
environment where you whether it's just
as a stripper or a hooters girl or even
an escort what does it taught you about
men
that men ain't [ __ ]
yeah
that's how i feel my slang
slogan is like men are trash
that's how i feel really
i've met so many different walks of men
and
you know i don't judge them for engaging
in sex work in any way but i've seen
some [ __ ]
so
i i have i've had trust issues before
sex work so now i just have no interest
in relationships in general
have you been in love before oh yeah
yeah
many times i'm a hopeless romantic but
you've soured on that yeah i've chosen
not to date or get involved romantically
until i retire from this life
so i haven't had like
unpaid casual sex in over a year
everything any sexual thing i've done
has been for a payment
you know for over the past year
but it's how you survive yeah and i
enjoy my job
i enjoy it but i don't think that
everyone would enjoy it so that's why i
don't advise people to do it
what was the best example of a loving
relationship you had when you were young
um
[Music]
like
between a man and a woman oh um
no probably my first relationship you
know my
like for your parents or oh okay um like
an example of a loving relationship yeah
um
probably my grandparents for a while but
then you know they eventually separated
but
they uh they really held it together
when i was a kid
they were a good example
of strong people who could uh
be there for each other you know
being a sex worker can be a lonely life
right very
very and i live alone and i like that
like i could easily have a roommate to
help me with rent and things but i don't
want to
does it build your self-esteem or knock
it down or
it builds mine yeah for sure i think uh
you get a lot of attention from guys
yeah like um i definitely wasn't the
most confident person growing up so this
is definitely about my confidence and
got me in touch with my femininity which
i didn't really have before so i really
am grateful for that what's been your
your best story your best experience
while doing this kind of work
uh best experience you've had
good nights where you made a lot of
money yeah
um i'm trying to think it's whether like
a club night or like and client outcall
night
i mean probably my most favorite client
but can't say too much about him but
he's not looking for names yeah i know
names but definitely um my highest paid
client that's probably been the
highlight of my sex work career was
meeting
him so when you're boiling down this
this whole life
it's very clear that it's
the attention of a female or sex for
money yes
do you believe that
love can can be something other than
that
um or will it always be about money and
no i believe in true love i just don't
wish to engage with it at this point in
my life
yeah
what's been your favorite memory in your
life
[Music]
favorite memory in my life
probably
jesus i don't know honestly um
have you been through rough things yeah
you know so it's not i don't have like
certain places like oh that was so good
it's more
getting out of
bad places or things you know it's been
like the most pivotal points in my life
that are probably my most favorite parts
of my life have you had rough
experiences as a sex worker um
i haven't ever been like sexually abused
or anything that i didn't consent for um
but i've been like scared before but
anytime i feel like something's off i
leave immediately and i've only had that
happen twice your intuition probably
gets very good yeah so if my intuition
tells me anything or i'm not comfortable
i leave because to me not all money is
good money so i'm perfectly fine
sacrificing the bag do you think you're
addicted to this this lifestyle
the fast money of it yes i think it's
definitely very addicting um
but i'm actually
doing the work to have a more concrete
exit plan right now because my plan was
to retire by the time i was 30.
which is in a few months and you're like
wait when is that yeah i think
uh yeah in a few months
so
i'm trying to fast track some things and
in the future if we follow back up
there'll be some really good news i
think i could share with you that's good
do you have some interesting stories of
some of your interactions with with men
doing this yes
very unique and i never judge so i feel
like that's why i get a lot of
people because they feel safe and
comfortable to be kinky or weird or
abstract with me what kind of odd
requests have you had
[Music]
there's a few and
one that stands out is a guy that i was
seeing
in a hotel and we had already done the
deed and i was using the restroom and
i'd seen him before so we're comfortable
with each other peeing in front of him
he's in the toilet and he's like are you
pooping and i'm like
maybe and he's like
can i see and i was like sure
and then he like picked my ass up a
little and then like looked behind and
he's like can i wipe it and i was like
that's not on my menu so i'm gonna have
to charge you for that and he was like
can i wipe it with my mouth
so he
licked my ass
clean when i had
pooped
and i charged a lot for that
of course of course and it's ugly is
that stuff that's worth more what do you
make of that what do you think that's
about you know
i'm into some weird things and i think
as long as
two adults are consenting
it's okay but where it stems from i
don't know you know
uh i mean i think i like certain sexual
things for
abstract reasons he's not hurting
anybody yeah he's not hurting anybody so
some good money
so let him i don't want to be judgmental
about it yeah but it is a
strange request yeah it's like let your
freak flag fly
because otherwise people get hurt
who
aren't sex workers because someone wants
to fulfill something like that with a
normal non-working girl you know so we
take that out of the normal society you
know and we i don't want to say endure
in a bad way but
we like eliminate that for them you know
from the public's mm-hmm yeah you're
almost like a therapist yeah it's very
much healing a lot of these a naked
therapist
so strip clubs have these vip rooms you
know a lot of girls will
yeah they won't say anything about the
vip realm and you know there's someone
get into crazy specifics but what
happens in the vip stays in the vip
it can be everything from i like to say
it's a customizable experience
so whatever girl needs to make she can
make in that back room yeah you know and
you don't always have to do the most to
make the most it's what
what goes on in the vip stretches from
full service to no service and you can
still make the same amount of money so
i've seen it and done it all i would say
what's your biggest regret
none
no regrets mm-hmm like
you learned from everything you've been
through yeah i don't regret any choices
i've made in my life not one
because i wouldn't be who i was without
making any of those mistakes and
i have completely built myself up from
all of that
do you believe in karma
and that's why i do not do shady [ __ ]
anymore
but i've been there you've done that
mm-hmm
and now i'm like it's not worth it
and now i just
give more
to receive more is what i do
and not take that's great
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
in my life
trust no one
i hear that a lot mm-hmm
that's what i say to anyone trust
yourself like trust your relationship
with yourself and your intuition so that
kind of goes along the lines
i don't like to rely on anybody
what advice would you give to a woman
who's thinking of doing some form of sex
work
to support yourself
immediately know your boundaries
for sure and
know what you're okay with and what
you're not okay with because you may not
know how to handle that situation
mostly i would say enforce your
boundaries and know your worth know your
price
all right spice thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah no problem wish
you the best of luck whatever you're
doing thanks appreciate it
you